In this video we shall review how to download reports from scans in BIP Suite Enterprise
Edition. There are a number of options available when downloading reports. You can do so by
navigating to the Scans tab and select the required scan. Now we can navigate to the
Reporting tab. From the drop-down we can select the report type that we want. Report types include a
summary HTML report or a detailed HTML report. You can also download a compliance report for OWASP
Top 10 2021 or PCI DSS version 3.2. Additionally we can export the data as burp XML by selecting the
Export Issue Data XML option. Once we have selected an option such as Detailed Report we can then
decide which severities to include and also if you want to include the false positive issues.
Once we've selected the relevant options we can click download.
Thank you.